hey what's up guys my name is China
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we mentioned that it's
probably a good idea while hazel is
still kind of early on in development to
actually talk about precompiled headers
and actually start using pre-compiled
headers so that's what we're going to do
today
getting close the previous episode
definitely watch it there that's what we
actually set up that event system that
we planned in the episode before that
but yeah today's gonna be all about
precompiled headers now I did last week
just make a video about precompiled
headers in the sample plus series so
check that out the reason I did that is
because obviously bringable headers are
more than just applicable through this
game engine that we're building and I
wanted to make a more generic the video
that's just about how they work and why
we want to use them so definitely check
out that video if you're not sure what a
precompiled header is because I'm not
gonna spend too much time explaining it
here that's like a 20 plus minute video
about freaking ball headers anyway so
instead of really talking about what
they are in this video we're just gonna
go ahead and implement them so yeah
watch that video first if you haven't
already and then let's just jump into
implementing precompiled headers so
looking at all of our hazel sauce here
there's obviously a bunch of stuff that
we're going to end up using that
requires the use of many kind of
standard library things like for example
we're including memory here in advance
you know including string we're
including functional all the thing all
of these things can be in a string
stream all these things can be moved
into a precompiled header and of course
this hazel project is quite young at the
moment we'd only been using like other
data structures like vector for example
um so it's a really good idea to
actually create that precompiled header
now because we don't have too many
source files which means we don't need
to spend too much time actually editing
things which is quite nice ok so the
first thing we're going to do is under
source I'm actually going to make a new
file which I'm gonna make a header file
and a CPP file and I'm gonna call it h
set PCH so hazel PCH H add and then also
we need to make a C++ file called H set
PCH dot CPP this will include our a
Giuseppe CH dot H file this is needed
for visual studio because visual studio
precompiled headers require a source
file which includes the break cobalt
header
whereas other compilers like lying in
Jesus he do not and then over here this
is gonna be a breaking ball to head on
so the first thing I want to do is if
we're actually in Windows so if H that
platform Windows I'm actually going to
include Windows dot H because that's
definitely going to be needed and that's
just something that we want to have
available to us if we're kind of if
winner is actually defined this is
something that does belong in a
precompiled header however obviously not
for all platforms we could make we could
make a pricking belt header be separate
for each platform I'm not gonna bother
with that I don't think that's 100%
necessary but maybe window specific or
other platform specific headers can
actually be included in this PC H with
this kind of if def and then over here
we'll put common stuff so stuff like
iostream stuff like memory you know
utility algorithm I'm not gonna put too
much stuff here functional what else did
we have and then you know data
structures like string vector probably
unordered map an ordered set I don't
want to waste too much time here we'll
kind of add stuff to this as we need
them of course but this is probably a
good set I think we also used s dream as
well probably makes more sense for this
to be with string like this but anyway
that's probably a Chad generally a good
idea of what we actually need if we go
through this it's a string functional
I'll start removing them as well from
here because we don't need them strength
stream straight stream we can just
include the break and bald head in
header files themselves by the way
doesn't just need to be in a safe a file
going through this cool cool cool cool
cool memory we have
yeah that's about it cool okay so
there's our precompiled header it's got
everything we need now let's go ahead
and add it to pre Meg so in hazel I'm
going to just kind of open that pre make
file yeah yeah we're gonna talk about
all we actually need to add to our
projects or specifically the hazel
project to actually use PCHS so the
first thing we need to specify is which
header file is our PCH so we're gonna
write PCH header and then the name of
the header file which is a chesed PCH
dot H like that that means use the hazel
PCH file right and then for visual
studio because it actually needs to
create a PCH file as well we need to
actually type PCH sauce now this can be
excluded on platforms in which we don't
need this or rather for compilers for
projects that we generate well we
actually don't need this but for visual
studio we do um so we don't have to put
this under like you know filter system
windows or anything it will just be
ignored on other kind of platforms cool
so and then here we actually need to
specify the full path so Hazel's source
and then H set P chcbp okay so that is
kind of the equivalent of us going ahead
and saying you know behavioral studio
please create my precompiled header file
and then this is the equivalent of kind
of just going into our project and being
like hey you know I'm going to use PC
ashes and it's going to be H set PC H
dot H okay so that's what that is all
about and let's not save our changes
here okay cool so that's all we need to
write again I've just done this for
hazel if you kind of end up with
substantial sandbox application you can
do that for sandbox as well but for now
that's all we need so let's rerun our
generate projects file there we go it's
done everything successfully if I reload
everything now we should be able to
right click here and see that this is
now marked as create and that in our
kind of project settings this is not as
used and H set PC H is the broken pilot
header to use cool so now let's do a
clean build of everything and of course
we get several errors because we need to
make sure that that H is that PC H the H
file is the first thing that's included
in every single city we file
so at the very top I'm going to include
a she said PCH okay and this will be
done for every single file now I think
sauce is actually in our in our compiler
include paths yes it is that should make
it easy just need to include that and
that's it
so application and then log dos CPP
every single CPP file we've only got
like two though so that's that's why I
wanted to get this done as quickly as
possible before this project starts
growing a lot so if we build this again
you can see that we get no errors it
built successfully and it took five and
a half seconds by the way as an example
that that's a clean build with breaking
ball headers or otherwise just do a
clean build for fun and see how long
Hazel takes to build so with Brigham
bolt headers a clean build takes six
seconds okay and without freaking bald
headers so I'll just set precompiled
headers to not using and then I'll
right-click clean right-click build you
can say take seven point six second so a
little bit longer not that much longer
however most the kind of build time
improvements are gonna come from just
editing individual source files so if I
just kind of I don't know I could just
add a space or something and then hit
build again this one applications let
CPP file you can see that it took three
seconds to recompile let's just do that
again just to have a better kind of more
reliable timing it's about three three
point three seconds and then I will
switch this to use friggin vault headers
I'll just build everything with this new
kind of thing and then once that is done
I'll have my space back hit build and
you can see it's quite a bit faster and
then if I remove my space and do my
build again there we go so consistently
faster now that we have precompiled
headers and that will only kind of get
faster and faster
as our project grows in size okay so
that's it you can see how easy it is to
actually integrate precompiled headers
it's really not annoying at all because
we didn't have to go through the 100
safety bit files we had and then add it
in right which would have been the case
if we had done this later on in the
series so I'm really happy to get us out
of the way as quickly as possible really
this should be part of your initial
project set up for any kind of large
project if you've decided to use
precompiled headers so there we go we
have that now and you can see how how
easy it is to actually do this kind of
stuff and pretty much just PCH header
and what was it actually I just forgot
what it's called
yeah pasting edge header in PCH sauce
and that's all you need and the PCH
sauce again and then it only needed if
you're using MS PC as your compiler okay
hope you guys enjoy this video if you do
you know the like button you can also
help support this series but got a
patron a couple / the Cherno huge thank
you as always to all the patrons that
make this series possible next episode
is already up for you guys and also the
development repository that you get
access to already has all this stuff
obviously written that's where I
implement everything way ahead of the
videos so if you're interested in that
definitely helps plot the series and
check that out I will see you guys next
time I think we're gonna finally be able
to start talking about Windows and like
layers and application kind of how that
in how that intertwines and just
application run loop and all that stuff
I think that's going to be the stuff
that we focus on next so finally we're
getting to the point where we might be
able to have a window on something on
the screen that's gonna be exciting I'll
see you guys in that video good bye
[Music]